Çeviri: Orkun Nazim Kadioglu
Gözden geçirme: Ahmet Erdogan Asliyuce
Herkese merhaba.
Bugün hem uygulamayla,
hem varolan,
daha önce yapılmış
Ebru uygulamalarıyla
Ebru'yu anlatmaya çalışacağım.
Belki hepiniz duymuşsunuzdur.
Ebru'nun bu sürekli artan,
ilgi toplayan tarafını,
Hepiniz fark etmişsinizdir son yıllarda.
Aslında pek şaşırmamak lazım.
Çünkü biraz güncel sanata uyum
sağlayan bir tarafı var.
Yani, biraz rastlantısal,
kendi kendine gelişen,
Özellikle güncel sanat dilleri
-yani video ve performans ile-
çok uyumlu olan bir tarafı var.
Açıkçası, bu yönüyle eskiler
buna "Zuhurat" demişler.
Yani her şeyi kontrol edemiyor olmanız,
Cüzi iradeniz ile ancak bir kısmını
yönlendiriyor olmanız
haline Zuhurat Sanatı demişler.
Zuhurat kelime anlamı bakımından
beklenmedik anda ortaya çıkan,
Bir anda oluşan, biraz aslında bizi
şaşırtan genel olaylara karşı
betimlediğimiz bir terim.
Şimdi, çok basit bir örnek ile aslında
çok müdahil olmadığımız
fakat ortaya çıkan desenlerin
hakikaten çok şaşırtıcı
olduğunu fark edeceğimiz
bir küçük deneme ile
sizi başbaşa bırakmak istiyorum.
Aslında çok müdahil
olmadığımı göreceksiniz.
Buraya, hali hazırda kurulmuş basit bir su
düzeneğine buradan boyaları akıtıp
nasıl sonuç elde ettğimize bakacağız.
Evet şimdi çok benzer bir uygulamayı
yıllar önce yapan,
Yani 1960'larda yapan başka bir
coğrafyaya gidelim.
Dünya'nın bambaşka bir
uygulamasını görelim.
Evet,
Bu görüntüde görmüş olduğunuz sanatçı
1960'larda bunu,
Aynı metodla rastlantısal bir şekilde
suyun üzerine yapıyor.
Ve, Aslında bunu yapanların kim olduğuna
dikkatli bir şekilde baktığımda
ancak düzene,
Yani kontrolcülüğe karşı çıkan
yine Zuhurat'a tabii olan
bir düşünce akımındaki
insanların yaptığını görüyoruz.
Bunlar hippiler.
1960'larda dünyanın birçok yerinde
bu tarz benzer uygulamalar yapıyorlar,
Ve aslında bu rastlantıyı onlar da
daha önce hayatlarının
merkezine koymuşlar.
Veya, şimdi hepimizin çok daha
yakından bildiği
bir başka sanatçının işlerine bakalım.
Aslında, neredeyse klasik Ebru'nun
damlatma tekniğine çok benzeyen,
Fakat Pop-art'ın Andy Warhol gibi çok
önemli bir temsilcisi gibi,
Jackson Pollock'nin yaptığı bu
hamleleri izleyelim.
Temelde hareketi baz alan...
Siz de Ebru'ya benzetebiliyor musunuz?
Ben bunu kendim mi öyle düşünüyorum?
Çünkü tamamı ile figürden,
Ve kontrolün dışında,
Rastlantısal olarak bir yöntem uyguluyor.
Biz de aslında birazdan bizim eskiden
beri biliyor olduğumuz
klasik Ebru'nun bir
uygulamasıyla bu benzeş.
Jackson Pollock'nin bu yaptığı
benzeşmeyi izleyebiliriz.
Aslında, temelde buradaki konu
güncel sanatın tam olarak
içine dahil olduğu
performans sanatlarına çok uyum
sağlayabiliyor olması.
Video dilinde bunun sürecinin
izleniyor olması.
Belki şöyle diyebiliriz:
Sonucundan çok,
sürecinin kıymetli olduğu,
Yani yolculuk sürecinin kıymetli olduğu,
Ve her an dönüşmeye,
değişmeye müsait
bir formunun olduğu bir görüntü.
Şimdi, Pollock'nin damlatla tekniğini
yani bizim klasik Ebru'da Battal
olarak tanımladığımız
bir görüntü ile başlayalım.
Daha sonra bunu şekillendirebiliriz.
Bence Ebru'nun en önemli tarafı
dinamik bir şekilde sürekli
değişiyor olması.
Mesela başlamış olduğumuz tek böyle bir formu
şimdi bambaşka bir yere götürme şansımız,
Fırsatımız var.
Aslında biz de sürekli o yolculuğun
bir parçası olduğumuzun farkındayız.
Bu Emoji'yi kullanmayan
var mı telefonunda?
(Gülüşmeler)
Evet, şimdi bunu tekrar dönüştürelim.
Ebru'nun dinamik tarafı burası:
Tam olarak başlamış olduğumuz bir formu
bambaşka bir forma çevirebiliyoruz.
Şimdi neredeyse artık
ulusal bir sembol haline dönüşmüş
başka bir forma geçelim.
Yani, bir lale formu.
Evet, şimdi sürekli dinamik
tarafından bahsediyorduk.
Tekrar başka bir dönüşüme devam edelim.
Evet.
Şimdi bunu kağıda asıp bakacağız.
Aslında Ebru'nun bir başka özelliği de
gerçekten birçok farklı yüzeye
transfer edilebilmesi.
Bunu siz teninize,
bambaşka bütün mat
malzemelere alabiliyorsunuz.
Herhangi bir hava boşluğu olmadığından
emin olmak için...
Belki de dünyada bu kadar
hızlı sonuç veren
bir başka sanat disiplini yok diyebiliriz.
Suyun hareketliliğinden çok
hızlı dönüşebiliyor.
(Alkış)
Çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Aslında belki de
belki de bu coğrafyaya özgü bir şey
bu Zuhurat.
Gerçekten bu kadar doğayı, hayatı
kontrol etme isteği,
Batı'da çok fazla.
Sosyal psikoloji araştırmalarında da çok
fazla gözlemlenebilen bir şey.
Çok fazla kontrolcülük var.
Ve bizim hayatımızda gerçekten bu daha
doğanın kendi haline gönüllü bir şekilde
teslim ettiğimiz bir süreç.
Bu sanatın dinamiklerinde de
sanki bizim hayatımıza dair
referanslar hissettim,
baştan beri.
Bu bizim dışımızda gelişen kısmı hep
benim için daha heyecanlı olmuştur.
Çünkü, her an bizi ayık tutuyor.
Her an var olduğumuz formun
dışına çıkarıyor.
Her an bizi aynı süreç içerisinde
sıkışmaya mahkum etmeyen,
sürekli bize yeni referanslar tattıran,
hatırlatan bir tarafı var.
Ve bu süreç boyunca ben
başladığım bu işlerle ilgili
sizinle şimdi birkaç plan
paylaşmak istiyorum,
Ve açıkçası ne kadar
birbirinden uzak alanlar
olduğunu vurgulamak için bunu yapacağım.
Çünkü, spesifik olarak
hiçbir olaya yönelip
onu derinleştirmek yerine,
Ebru'nun tıpkı bu ruhu gibi,
sürekli dönüşen,
değişen projelere göre evrildi
bugüne kadar yaptıklarımız.
Örneğin, Londra'daki bir moda haftasında
Klimt'in işlerini bir elbiseye
yorumladığımız bu görüntüler gibi...
Veya Oslo'da bir pop müzik klibini
yine Ebru'nun ritimleriyle
sesi yorumlamaya
çalıştığımız bu proje gibi...
Veya TED-Ed'in laboratuarda
bebeğin nasıl oluştuğu
ile ilgili biyolojik bir
belgelesine içerik
üretmeye çalıştığımız bu proje gibi...
Veya diyelim ki bir gösteri sanatlarından
Bir su gösterisinde,
Ebru'nun su perdesine yansıtılması gibi...
Veya bugüne kadar birçok şahsiyetin,
Veya dizinin içeriklerinin videolarını
yorumlamak gibi
portre çalışmalarıyla devam ettim...
Bundan sonra da aslında nasıl bir
yere evrileceği ile ilgili
gerçekten hiçbir fikrim yok.
Hiçbir plan da yapmıyorum.
Kendi kendime ürettiğim bir
proje bile yok neredeyse.
İnsanların sürekli fikirlerine
göre şekillenip
onu geliştirme çabası
içerisinde bulunuyorum.
Beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)
Çok sağ olun.